[Music]
growing up watching Harry Potter I
remember finding the sorting had to be
very intriguing how is it created and
how did it operate in a bizarre world of
magic where seemingly anything is
possible the sorting hat still sticks
out as one of the strangest things
floating around from its physical
appearance to its role of choosing the
houses for students it really is
peculiar if you're watching this video
you probably already know what the
sorting hat is but if somehow you don't
it's basically just a filthy old frayed
dirty Hat the Hat is extremely outspoken
and is praised by professors and
students alike for its uncanny ability
to assign houses to Hogwarts students
the primary functions the sorting hat at
Hogwarts is to assign new students to
one of the four houses Gryffindor
Hufflepuff Ravenclaw or Slytherin the
Hat is a sentient being that originally
belonged to Godric Gryffindor and the
Hat was actually produced by Godric and
the other three founders of Hogwarts
Rowena Ravenclaw Helga Hufflepuff and
Salazar Slytherin to perform its task
the Hat uses legitimacy which is the art
of magically navigating through a
person's mind someone who is proficient
at practicing legitimacy is referred to
as illegitimate
notable the gentleman's include Severus
Snape Albus Dumbledore and vaulting self
the Hat will navigate the layers of the
wearer's mind and after careful
consideration announced its decision
loudly so that all can hear after
founding the school the four founders
encountered a bit of dilemma when it
just occurred to them that they would
have to figure out a way to sort
students by house when they would no
longer alive however this dilemma was
short-lived as Godric Gryffindor quickly
provided a solution to their problem
Godric pulled his completely normal hat
off of his head and made the suggestion
to the other founders that using their
collective magic they in chant the Hat
and turn it into a sentient being the
founders of Hogwarts
recognize that they each valued very
different virtues virtues which ended up
leading to the defining attributes of
each house it was important to them
their houses they founded would continue
to follow by the beliefs from which they
were based these virtues or inherent
characteristics can be summed up in the
sorting has own words by Gryffindor the
bravest were prized for beyond the rest
for ravenclaw the cleverest would always
be the best for Hufflepuff hard workers
were most worthy of admission and power
Hungary Slytherin loved those of great
ambition essentially how it works is
this upon placing the sorting hat on
your head it will begin to analyze your
mind and place you in a house based on
how closely you resemble one of the four
founders if the Hat senses great bravery
Gryffindor is the likely choice if the
Hat senses great intelligence
ravenclaw is a likely choice if the Hat
senses that someone is a hard worker
hufflepuff is the likely choice and
finally if the Hat senses that someone
is hungry for power then Slytherin is a
likely choice it has been speculated
that the Hat has a tendency to place
students in houses based on the
qualities they value and not necessarily
qualities that they actively personify
additionally the Hat can detect nascent
qualities in a student and generally
places them in the house that will
challenge them the most
pushing their character to the test a
good example of this is neville
longbottom very rarely every 50 years or
so to be exact a hat store will occur
during the sorting hat ceremony this is
when the sorting hat needs additional
time to come up with a decision usually
it is considered a hat stall when
decision takes 5 minutes or longer this
usually occurs when a student has a
personality that could be considered
equally suitable for each of the
Hogwarts houses in the case of this
occurrence the hats may take the
students personal preference into
consideration for its decision known hat
stalls include Minerva McGonagall who
wavered between Gryffindor and Ravenclaw
and Peter Pettigrew who wavered between
Gryffindor and Slytherin
despite Pettigrew betraying the order of
Phoenix and aiding Voldemort
insisted that it had made the right
choice in fact according to the Hat it
has never made a mistake the Hat always
backs his original decision regardless
of whether or not the student acts in
accordance with the values of their
assigned house near hat stalls
encroaching on that five-minute mark
include filius Flitwick Gilderoy
Lockhart Hermione Granger Neville
Longbottom and Harry Potter something
interesting about the Hat that I thought
I would share is that JK Rowling had
many other plans in mind for assigning
students before eventually landing on
the hat in her words the first was an
elaborate Heath Robinson ish machine
they did all kinds of magical things
before reaching indecision but I did not
like it it felt at once too complicated
and too easy
her next idea was to place four statues
of the four founders in the entrance
hall which came alive and selected
students from the throng in front of
them while the school watched lastly she
wrote a list of the ways in which people
can be chosen eenie meenie miney moe
short straws chosen by team captains
names out of a hat names out of a
talking hat putting on a hat the sorting
hat and with all of that that concludes
the video if you guys have any further
questions about the sorting hat or if
you have any ideas for videos that you'd
like us to make then please leave a
comment down below enjoy the rest of
your day and remember
sucks
[Music]